[Musique]
il avait quand même construit tout un
alibi pour aider ton père avoir une
maîtresse c'est vrai que c'était un
petit peu limite de sa part
en fait ma belle-famillement que mes
parents soient présents au mariage ah
merde
on loue des faux parents comme on a fait
pour le fils de Francis Lalanne hors de
question les alibi c'est terminé
j'arrive pas à croire qu'on soit là mais
c'est impossible on n'a jamais fait une
mission si risquée ça va se passer comme
sur de la crème
[Musique]
profite de cette journée elle va être
mémorable
je vous souhaite d'être un modèle de
bonheur et de fidélité comme les ta mère
et
c'est déjà bien